allez vas-y françois tu es prête oui
attention mon service
ah non non non non elle était dehors
pour moi bon ça fait 5 points pour toi
et 3 pour moi comme au sefi 5 à 0 j'ai
pas marqué un seul coup
ça allait pas de tricher bible mais
j'essayais pas tricher le nom je suis
bonne foi ou enfin vous avez pu
m'atteindre pour jouer au tampon au ping
pong bon on va le donnez moi une
raquette j'aurais vous flanquer une
raclée
casimir nous sommes déjà en train de
faire une partie du attente au cern où
des arbitres savoir un service
excellent service de julie coulera
lefrançois couvre julie coulaud
s'asseoir un revers monique robert balle
au filet pas de cours françois couvre
giuly comment françois attention france
ô folies de droite s'emploie et amorce
un virage au splendid mais
malheureusement propos des rentes et se
casse la figure ans la jolie à gauche
écoutez j'ai attrapé un macaroni désigné
on dirait torticolis bravo julie du a
gagné la première manche ou fou et bien
avant la seconde manche je te suggère de
venir prendre un bain ça nous fera du
bien la bonne idée casimir du lien avec
nous non non je vais rester là je vous
faire une petite partie pousse hall tous
tout seul comme un gros bonhomme en
grand casimir l'on ne peut pas jouer au
ping pong tout seul il faut au moins
être deux quand on veut on peut bravo
pavement et fait des expériences même
casimir
alors voilà il s'agit de réfléchir si je
joue assez lentement je devrais avoir le
temps de courir de l'autre côté pour la
rattraper voyons
raté j'ai perdu non j'ai gagné puisque
c'est également moi qui ai envoyé la
balle de ce côté
tiens une balle qui roule n'amasse pas
mousse
étranges petites choses un jeu du soin
bah oui mais pas vu ma balle à la wass y
aller mais que penses tu de ce petit
chef-d'oeuvre que je suis en train de
peindre sur le dos d'un timbre poste
est petit
un minuscule mais le plus petit tableau
de l'île aux enfants du grâce à montano
j'arrive à peur non pas comme tous les
autres peintres habituel sur des toiles
mais sur n'importe quelle surface plane
à deux reprises le génie rabon dites-moi
si moi aussi je peignais sur une très
grande surface plane qui ne soit pas une
toile est ce que je frisera noah aussi
pourquoi pas enfin moi même j'ai cherché
très longtemps cette surface aussi plané
aussi grande je doute que tu en trouves
une eh bien c'est ce qu'on va voir qu'on
ne ferait on pas pour friser le génie
[Musique]
voilà il ne me reste plus qu'à signer
casimir ça y est les enfants rené là
venez vous allez m'aider on va faire un
jeu j'ai fait ce grand tableau mais ça
s'appelle les saisons mais je ne suis
pas sûr de ne pas me tromper alors je
voudrais que vous m'aidiez alors
regardez bien ces quatre peintures et
dites-moi laquelle représente le
printemps
lequel larmes avec les folies vers
d'accord un l'été le télé l'été c'est le
soleil l'automne la feuille et bat le
quatrième l'hiver à
sémalens de neige merci les enfants
grâce à vous je ne me suis pas trompé on
va les jouer maintenant merci un
monsieur du snapo navy carey qui est un
moment casimir je vous présente un
chef-d'oeuvre de m casimir cela
s'appelle les quatre saisons c'est la
plus grande oeuvre peinte sur l'île aux
enfants sur un support qui ne soit pas
une toile
casimir est tout simplement géniale dans
mes bras après ce chef-d'oeuvre tu peux
être mon égal je m'appelais fulbert
quand elle sent vieux fulbert
alors casimir et c'est toi qui appelle
sur notre table de ping-pong points et
alors c'est beau hein on peut tu
exagères alors résine here tu va
remettre immédiatement cette table sur
ses quatre pieds pour que nous puissions
continuer notre partie de ping pong non
non c'est impossible
parce que ma peinture n'est pas sèche
mes chers amis je me permets
d'intervenir en faveur de ce fait c'est
un comble monsieur du snowboard non
seulement casimir 20 sur deux tables de
ping-pong mais ensuite il faut que cet
autre film et puis je savoir casimir sur
quoi nous allons terminer notre parti et
bien vous pouvez continuer sur la le
timbre poste de super il est sa clinique
[Musique]